Kelly Clarkson is spreading the love how
kate beckinsale got her groove back and
what's the deal with drake and josh you
two okay hey friends this is the daily
Jenny and I'm Denny direct oh and there
is some love in the air no not for me
but for some lucky Kelly Clarkson fans
who got engaged in Las Vegas with
Kelly's help what looks like a normal
backstage meet-and-greet turned to this
[Applause]
you are like a part of it Kelly Alex
Miller planned to pop the question a
longtime boyfriend Justin Blake and
Kelly was in on it the whole time after
Alex got to meet with her solo now we
caught up with a newly engaged couple
via Skype this morning about how it all
went down
our first night I told her you know I've
been thinking about playing a proposal
to him during the show and she's like he
should have told me like you could have
come up on stage we could have done it
all together after the show when I saw
her and I got to speak to her she was
like let's do this go get him let's do
it now and I was like oh okay I can do
that I can do that the guys told us it
was a life-changing moment that they
will never forget and Kelly is more than
welcome to attend the wedding in fact
they said she can officiate and this is
my opportunity at beyonce to officiate
my future wedding thank you very much
I'll be waiting for your call B all
right well Kelly is not the only star
spreading the love these days I'm
looking at you kate beckinsale after
splitting from husband Len Wiseman after
11 years of marriage at the end of 2015
he's got her a hot younger man he's
learned that Kate is officially dating
comedian Matt Wright she's 43 he's 21
and they're not shy about their PDA yeah
we spotted them making out Tuesday
outside a club in West Hollywood
California so who is the guy well I can
tell you he's a stand-up comic
feature on Nick Cannon's wild and out
they met through Sarah Silverman who by
the way is dating Kate ex actor Michael
Sheen now we know Kate is into fitness
and clearly he's got that down regularly
lane thirst traps all over his Instagram
and like Kate he's also a cat lover now
even though that is only three years
older than Kate's daughter a source
tells us the entire family thinks he's
the nicest and most lovely person so a
funny animal lover that's the family
approved without for days Kate
Beckinsale you are winning that life
i'ma give you guys a seven on the John
and Chrissy scale two extra points for
abs all right cool now sticking with a
love theme today I want to talk to you
guys about my first love pizza I'm just
kidding it's all food so which is why I
have a special treat for you it's a
sneak peek at Hannah Hart's new Food
Network show I heart food and a loves
food so much she is hitting the road
eating everything in sight and in this
exclusive clip she visits Asheville
North Carolina for the story behind
southern staple cat's head biscuits take
a look okay ladies oh this is our
signature biscuit it's a mimosa fried
chicken biscuit a mimosa Fried Chicken
Vidya wait is it asheville or is it is a
head of it look the whole edible brine
it in champagne and orange juice before
we fry it it's got sriracha slop it's a
little bit of a kick in there not too
much one one thing I need a moment I
need a moment with the business I get
you someone who looks at you the way
Hannah looked at that biscuit here's my
biscuit all right I heart food premieres
on Food Network on August 14th now
moving on to some drama between Drake
and Josh Josh Peck got married to Paige
O'Brien last weekend and while his
grandfathered co-star John Stamos scored
an invite apparently his on-screen
brother
Drake Bell was not invited to the
wedding and that did not sit well with
Bell and now deleted tweets Bell said
ties are officially cut with his former
co-star he wrote when you're not invited
to the wedding the message is clear and
add
it I'll miss your brother yeah all right
P childhood now this must be some sick
plot twist because the to literally
shared the same throwback photo just
last week what went wrong guys well on
Thursday during an interview on
allegedly with Theo von and Matthew Cole
Weiss Josh said the two aren't as close
anymore
when people see Drake and I together and
it rarely happens just because he's
working and I'm working it's like
there's like what what do you what what
are you I think you probably always have
been together and just never not been
together probably yeah like I have no
good answer for when people and I get it
all the time which is like where's Drake
event the number one question you get
all the time oh yeah yeah yeah like I
wish had a better answer but probably at
home whole food yeah well listen what is
Drake eating at Whole Foods because have
you seen these Drake issuing off his
six-pack in a shirtless photo shoot for
flaunt magazine so apparently he's at
home licking his wounds and doing
crunches good for you Drake
alright before we sign off there is some
exciting movie news today just two days
after the two directors for the untitled
Han Solo movie were fired and hired a
new one and with that we have the queen
of Star Wars and all things movie ash
crossing I'm sure a pool ready bow hello
they have announced a new director two
days later it's just this little indie
director named Oscar winner Ron Howard
boom and get this ailment keeping that
may 2018 release date and they start
filming July 10th
are you breathing because it was
touch-and-go the first time I was on a
plane when that news broke it was not
okay also and quickly also exciting the
Jurassic world sequel has a name it has
a release date what do you know yes so
it's one year from today you are getting
Jurassic world falling kingdoms dun dun
dun so yes Bryce Dallas Howard starring
in that one her dad is doing the Han
Solo movie Colin Trevorrow is doing
Episode nine so I'm thinking put fries
Dallas Howard seen a Star Wars put it
out there ash put it out there there it
is in the universe thank you so much you
know this is not your show so it's time
for you to go but you can see more of
this cross and over on et at the movies
we have that new episode up now thank
you guys so much for watching be sure to
hit subscribe to eat
YouTube channel for more daily Denny and
et at the movies and of course all these
stories and more over at ET online.com
time to be to dance my way out here at
goodbye